okay so now you're getting attacked by
the dragon and you have to like scream
at this tennis ball george rr martin
based house of the dragon on a real
generational long familial war with an
incredible crew building massive set
pieces a dedicated cast plowing through
injuries and the bucking bronco that
acts as a dragon stand-in we have a lot
to talk about here it's a different
story with different actors with sort of
different people making it with the same
ambitions number one it's a pretty big
one you get that great call which is the
thing that every writer is hoping for
telling you we're gonna go make this
thing george r.r martin was actually
pretty nervous about handing his work
over to writer ryan j condell and
director miguel sapochnick and then you
realize the responsibility that's on
your shoulders he describes the feeling
as handing your baby over to foster
parents but with his direct involvement
and ryan's promise to remain faithful to
the world george realized he found the
best people to bring it to life
there's always a little suspense to how
good is it going to be but i think i'm
in good hands ryan and miguel number two
they obviously used cgi for the dragons
themselves
but the actors did get something almost
as intimidating to react to we have this
big buck which is a bit like a bucking
bronco and it moves around and it's
mechanical not only do the broncos move
about but there's also tons of wind
being shot into the actors faces so the
reactions to the dragon you'll see on
screen are very linear to what's
happening on set and they add our big
beautiful dragons on top of that in
post-production number three we have to
talk about these wigs
oh my god the wigs it's a number to get
into them apparently these wigs add an
exponential amount of time spent in the
makeup chair but it's a mixed bag as far
as how the actors feel about them some
felt like the wig really brought out the
authenticity in their character while
others just found them to be a hassle
and then you've got all the you know the
battle scenes and where the wigs get
destroyed from all the blood and the
gunk again we're talking more time in
the makeup chair you can just see the
despair
from the hair and makeup team number
four of course there are going to be a
few onset mishaps with all those swords
being swung around
our first rehearsal with matt i smashed
him in the face with a sword fabian
frankel is definitely a believer in the
practice makes perfect method and i
thought it was going to get hired pretty
quickly thankfully he's had enough
practice since that first rehearsal and
he's gotten a lot better at the battle
scenes so yeah getting better
number five
now that must have been a shock
surprisingly olivia cook who plays
alison hightower hadn't watched game of
thrones before she auditioned i realized
that i had been auditioning with
cersei's scenes after getting cast and
watching it she was incredibly grateful
that she hadn't seen it beforehand i was
so happy i hadn't watched it because i
would have just mimicked absolutely
everything that she had done number six
not only did matt enjoy a nice sword to
the face
but he also suffered a much more serious
injury to a disc in his neck the injury
took place during a stunt in portugal
and he didn't even stop working he just
pushed forward despite being in severe
pain throughout filming he told the
hollywood reporter it's a pain in the
neck literally physically and
metaphorically he was still in physical
therapy months after the show had
already wrapped it's a big challenge for
all of it all of us that have taken it
on number seven there are quite a few
things the actors still want to steal
from the set yeah my knife i wanted to
keep it but um
you know they're very hot on that on the
show one of the reasons they're so
protective over all the props and
costumes is because everything is custom
made for the show all the costumes are
bespoke all the all the all the weapons
are custom made for the show everything
you see even the banners hanging from
the wall is specifically designed for
that moment or scene we have a specific
uh budget line item in season two for
custom severed heads number eight sorry
how many dragons
one of the first things ryan j condell
worked with miguel sapochnikon was
differentiating all 17 dragons from one
another for about a year before filming
started utilizing various concept
designers and of course
george who writes very detailed books
gave us the gift of specifying color and
size and age ryan's method behind giving
personalities to the dragon also depends
on who is riding them like correct seas
he's always moving and flexing he's
never he never sits still
much like his rider there are dragons
that were designed we won't even get to
see in season one
number nine
we are getting into the method behind
the madness here george rr martin
loosely based game of thrones on the war
of the roses house of the dragon is
based on an earlier period in english
history called the anarchy i pilfered
freely from real history when henry the
first was left with only one child his
daughter matilda he made her his heir
but after he passed the lords of the
kingdom did not honor it her cousin
stephen came in and stole the treasury
out from under her and got crowned king
this is where the storyline for house of
dragon comes into play maude or matilda
she was known and stephen fought for a
decade two decades whatever yeah number
ten now this was neat something ryan and
miguel were really impressed with were
emily carey's ability to get into
character through journaling when we
meet her character alison she doesn't
have a mother there was some some gaps
that we had to fill and so to sort of
figure it all out i just i just started
journaling it was one of the most useful
things she did to hone in on her
character story and with the advice of
miguel and ryan i managed to come up
with
some form of backstory number 11. you'd
be surprised how much was actually built
practically i feel that no one told them
that that isn't how films are made now
that you don't have to build the whole
castle king's landing was built
completely from the ground up and it was
twice as large as anyone could have
imagined it to be after reading the
scripts
you walk around these sets that look
like ancient monuments and buildings
with massive statues number 12 keep an
eye out for the visionary behind this
world george r.r martin may randomly pop
up in the series he did do a cameo in
the original game of thrones pilot but
unfortunately they ended up reshooting
most of the pilot so i was left on the
cutting room floor he was also supposed
to be a severed head but that idea got
nuked because they found out how
expensive a custom severed head would be
so they decided to go a cheaper route
they just bought a box of used severed
heads number 13. adaptations are tricky
ryan j condell found when it came to
bringing this book to the screen the
most difficult thing was the way it was
written george r.r martin calls the
novel a fake history book so when you're
reading it there is not a lot of
dialogue to go off of
you have point a and point c but you
don't really know what point b was
another complicated aspect of it was how
much time needs to be covered the story
goes on for generations i was figuring
out how to structure it in such a way
that we could move people through this
very complex timeline number fourteen
let's just say it was a big cast one
thing george rr martin loved about
making this show was that hbo didn't
limit him on how many characters were
allowed in the story in past reviews for
game of thrones critics would bash how
many characters the show had and how
hard it was to keep track of them um i
don't want to underestimate the
intelligence of the audience or the
readers you you can keep track of them
oftentimes when turning a novel into a
series they end up having to eliminate
or combine characters
george didn't want to do that the
audience is more sophisticated than
sometimes uh people making television
number 15. game of thrones has always
been all over the map
so it's safe to say house of the dragon
won't be any different for the interior
shots they camped up at leavesden
studios in england with several outdoor
shots in cornwall devon and surrey as
well as european locations like spain
and portugal with an incredible writer
director cast and crew behind george r.r
martin's legendary writing we couldn't
be more excited to devour everything
house of the dragon has to offer what
are you most excited to see